as this is your first news conference
since your appointment can I give you
this opportunity to apologize to world
leaders you may or may not have been
rude to over the last 12 months and ask
us what your your strategy is to try and
rebuild trust look I mean we get I think
we could almost been an awful long time
going over lots of stuff that I've
written over the last 30 years of some
serious issues and all of it in my view
have been taken out of mind there's some
serious issues before us today a
humanitarian crisis real problems in
Egypt on the agenda tonight and of
course that the continuing crisis in in
Yemen
our ambassador the you and Brussels so I
just spent the evening with the other
night had the privilege were going to
Oxford with Boris Johnson and in fact
worse Johnson got him to come into the
Oxford Union of which Boris was
president and talked to me about some
great experiences that they had together
there and he told me that this man is a
very smart and capable man that's the
Boris Johnson I calculated I have met
and that's the Boris Johnson that I
intend to work with and we intend to
make good things happen it's going well
John thank you very much whew
I think I think we go through that one
all right thank you thank you thank you
very much
Secretary of State you've accused the
current US President Barack Obama of
harboring a part Kenyon's quote
ancestral dislike for the British Empire
unquote while claiming I think
untruthfully at the time that he didn't
want a Churchill bust in the White House
you've described a possible future u.s.
president Hillary Clinton as someone
with quote dyed blonde hair and pouty
lips and a steely blue stare like a
sadistic nurse in a mental hospital
unquote you've also likened her to Lady
Macbeth do you take these comments back
or do you want to take them with you
into your new job as some sort of
indicator of the type of diplomacy you
will practice and then for the Secretary
of State given that mr. Johnson led a
campaign that your government viewed
pretty universally as detrimental to UK
EU and even US interests what confidence
do you have that as foreign secretary
mr. Johnson will represent the interests
of anyone but himself is the mr. Johnson
you saw during the referendum campaign
what the UK EU and US needs right now at
a time of so many challenges I couldn't
hear the last sentences is the mr.
Johnson you saw campaigning before the
referendum the type of man you think the
UK the EU and the US needs right now at
a time of so many challenges thank you
okay you want me to go first just just
don't death thank you for giving me an
opportunity ready to repeat a point that
I made earlier on I'm afraid that in the
there is a such a rich thesaurus now of
things that I've said that
Ben one way or another through what
alchemy I do not know somehow
misconstrued that it would really take
me too long to engage in a full
globality Nureyev apology - to all
concerned and and and I think most
people most people who read these things
in their proper context can see exactly
what was intended and indeed I find that
but everybody I've met so far in this
job understands that very well
particularly on the international scene
and we have some very serious issues
before us today we have a unfolding
humanitarian crisis in Syria which as I
said earlier on is getting worse and
worse we have to come up with some
answers there we have real problems in
Yemen which are currently intractable
and we have a burgeoning crisis in Egypt
those to my mind are far more important
than any obiter dicta that you may
disinter from 30 years of journalism the
people of Britain voted this is
democracy we all expected democracy yes
it is a fact President Obama and I both
said we thought that we would be better
off with a continuation of UK's
membership within the EU and that's a
well-known fact but that's not the way
the people of this country voted and we
respect democracy all of us
therefore it is our job to implement in
the best way possible what people voted
for and to try to guarantee that the
response is is gonna meet their standard
not ours that's the ultimate arbiter of
this so I am absolutely confident yes
that post referendum that we're going to
work together and we talked about
specific things that we need to do to
try to avoid negative consequences and
work on the positive ones and and I do
know this as I said earlier and I'm not
throwing this away as a casual comment
of diplomacy but I believe that
secretary Johnson
brings considerable intellect and value
that use to this initiative and I look
forward to working with him mr. foreign
secretary I understand that you don't
want to revisit the past perhaps but you
have an unusually long history of wild
exaggerations and frankly outright lies
that I think you foreign secretaries
have prior to this job and I'm just
wondering how mr. Kerry and others
should believe what you say considering
this very very long history and and mr.
Kerry I appreciate the First Amendment
in then your right to free speech
I think we need chapter and verse on
this you know this is what you would do
if you're in my I'm sorry let me just
let's go repeat my my point which is
that you know I think people are more
than welcome to to rake over stuff I've
written over many many years but I think
the most important thing is to get on
with the very heavy agenda we have
before us today and to try and sort out
if we can some of the intensifying
problems were seeing particularly in in
Syria I think most most most people who
are paying their taxes would rather that
those were our priorities